il sera là pour le moment il ya valérie
bénaïm valérie bénaïm qu'est ce que
c'est c'est la baloche c'est l'avalanche
et l'avalanche en carton et m'a dit
comment ça va il ya une année à vide à
iba alors là valérie bénaïm pour valérie
bénaïm les enchères démarrent à 50 ans
tu lis mieux 50 euros pour une médaille
100 euros pour mille à ivry 202 centres
mais les 1000 pour benhaim d'accord cent
mille 3000 bobigny oui je me sois mis 3
et 50 trouver un premier 50 3050 ben
bella elle a déjà vendu
la médaille
mais ça ne lisent pas mais n'at il donc
quitte patoche pour 3050 euros c'était
ça s'est réglé salut patoche ban bac je
prends les magistrats nous 50 euros à
moi les antilles à voile et vacances